Тетяна німці вона б могла з косово то
рішення міської ради для перейменування
маши 73 вулиця радіанс кімі та
комуністичного названих броварах
актрис до кожної ще протеїни самої
дегуманізації am i the divine проведення
і від прикладу а ми можемо провести його
обличчя Кирпоноса випадкового вона була
пряму на честь
роднянського герої в рамадан і проти
адже промивання вона навіть за
перемелювання all i wanna die брала
пепсі і хочеш ще б назвав піти було
поливу тобто історично назвалася і
олл-ін на євро howo надовго громадян їм
нарізала івановичу героїв упа
посилка скажете на тисячу влада вона
адже розібрати нормальна компанія
направила до метро карпєєва мастики
активісти член робочої групи з
перейменування занедбана
у нас публікував у змі маса за крима
вас ця які доносу вода шкірні хати
публікувався пропозиції так то безодня ти
йому злі люди свої пропозиції насилав і
виглядає вірним їх розгадала комісія не
скоро договорить проголосувала за
програвання в уловити виродок йому на лузі
руку видно законам дикої магів
провести декомунізацію частку того
наскільки в залі перспективніша дорога вниз
удаві поза ви в рамках вони світили мишах
адміністративної досконалості суду
потрібно інтересах державою і мало йому
вірна що за таких високих вартових
рамках і кидаються законом навички на не
dokumu нізації буду треба на може бути
проклянуть і рішеннями іскра у рішенні
теппер садовий поза суть його за найму і
пара іменування до метро короп здається в
броварах декомунізація в принципі
соботович а піти
знімаються нові назвати а видиху ви сядь
стане табличкою у суди можна по батькові і
з оборони не законом радіанс киси вали
таємницю дуриш ніку місія ціна після
прозорий НКВД мало за tortilla на вигляд
все він порубала
до метро разом меншими активістами його
вирішив брати участь у судовому процесі
набір квітів та .
миск раді ти тягну також петрою мультики
як ти вести у нас тут на засіданні про
означало на середину травня
судновий процес розик розстебнутий
нами мережі